hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Cicero begins his work on duty in which
he is explaining stoic ethics and in
particular the conception of duty by
talking about some general issues and he
uses from Latin terms like you know qui
steel which we might translate as
question or inquiry deliberate Co
deliberation consideration all of these
are the words that sort of signify like
big-picture issues and distinctions that
that we want to make sort of putting
everything in order from the start
Cicero loves you know an orderly
presentation of things so he begins by
talking about any inquiry about duty
about ethey qiyam about what it is that
we ought to do is really going to start
by if it's going to be comprehensive
it's going to have to look at two kinds
of things one is what the supreme good
or Feeney's is for for human beings he
talks here about the Venus were actually
Phenom because it's in the accusative
bone Oram the the end of goods or we
translate that sometimes as the supreme
good the good that encompasses or that
that provides the meaning to the other
goods we could also talk about the the
you know ultimate evil or ultimate bad
thing as well and Cicero does discuss
this in another work called the on the
ends or a de finibus right so he's not
going to really talk about that in this
work the on duties and the the thing
that he's really more interested in is
the rules the pre kept T's for for
living for how we ought to use things or
or deal with things how we ought to
comport ourselves in our life and of
course these are connected with each
other because the rules for living are
the rules that are supposed to get us to
the point of enjoying the ultimate good
and avoiding the the ultimate evil
but they're also supposed to bring along
some other things on the way so that's
the first thing that he discusses it in
this work he says that you know we have
to think about you know special duties
positive rules all these sorts of things
as being affected by the supreme good
being oriented towards them but he talks
about these seem to look rather to the
regulation of of everyday life of the
life that most of us are living most of
the time and that's what he wants to
talk about in this work he also brings
up another important distinction that we
can make which you know connects up but
not mapping exactly on to this but but
it's kind of the same idea he talks
about duties being separated into duties
that are absolute and then duties that
are mean and by mean they they lead to
something else they are a medium you
could say and the absolute duties are
those that are right rectum in in Latin
or in Greek Catholic Katherine mock the
duties that are literally like you know
right there the way they're supposed to
be they are ordered they're after the
thing that is Straits that is right it's
a little bit difficult to describe this
without getting metaphorical but then we
have these other duties that don't you
know present themselves to us as
absolutes but our reasonable ways to
realize these these absolutes something
he says for which a good reason can be
given and that is a thick iam in this
distinction when you man direct them and
in Greek it's cafe con and the Stoics
did make this distinction in fact
between these the Stoics are the ones
who actually come up with this term Kath
echoes Cafe Cohen really or yeah all
sorts of variations on it
and it means that which is is befitting
so this is the difference between what
is you know sort of automatically right
and what is right in the conditions or
what's right because it leads to
something else but it's still incumbent
upon us to do now Cicero starts to get a
bit more specific in saying well really
we're mostly interested in these these
lower-level things we're not going to
worry about the ultimate end we're gonna
worry more about these rules or these
these injunctions or imperatives for how
it is that we want to live so he talks
about a deliberate CEO that has in
effect five parts he's gonna say pinenut
pantheous who's this other philosopher
who he's taking a lot of on duties from
is coming up with three of these but
there's really five so he's going to lay
them out and these are for the sort of
choices that we might make the ways in
which we could live these choices could
be right they can be wrong they can be
in accordance with duty they can be out
of accordance with duty these are ways
to understand the the modalities of
these choices so the first one is the
question well is something actually
morally right or morally wrong and for
the Stoics not every single thing is
going to be right or wrong there's going
to be some things that are indifferent
but there are some things that are
definitely right and there are some
things that are definitely wrong we
won't have to go into those here there's
plenty of other discussions yet to come
in in the the work then he talks about a
second one is something expedient and
what do we mean by expedient that's the
translation that's being used here for
duty today what is what is useful what
is you might say workable is is another
word that we like to use ourselves and
so what are examples of those sorts of
things well you know wealth or houses or
positions or political authority or
reputation all of those sorts of things
are very useful for us to have that are
good in a sense but they're not good in
an absolute sense they're not always
morally right and wrong although our use
of them can in fact be right or wrong
for the Stoics and so you know we have
two different classes the morally right
or wrong or the expedient or the the not
expedient the useful and the useless or
the the harmful to those sorts of
interests then we get to something
really interesting and this is where we
often run into a lot of issues morally
right what if we run into cases where
the right the morally right and the
expedient conflict where we can do the
thing that's expedient but we have to
transgress the right in order to do that
that's a matter of choice right not
everybody makes the right choice when it
comes to those sorts of things so we
want to be able to lay out the conflict
that's actually taking place if we want
to approach ethics in a systematic way
now Cicero then says penalty is talked
about these but he didn't talk about
these other two which is where we run
into a lot of our moral dilemmas and
where we have to engage in deliberation
and that's where we're dealing with you
might say multiple goods that have to be
prioritized when we have two things that
are right but they can't both be
realized which of them is the more right
which of them is better than the other
good that's a key question that comes up
over and over and over again in ethics
and Cicero says what we actually need to
talk about that we need to examine that
if we want to understand what our duties
in fact are indeterminate cases great
example of this you've made a promise
making a promise fulfilling your promise
is the right thing to do but what if
fulfilling the promise harms other
people in the process not harming other
people that's also right we can say
harming is wrong
which of them should you favor well you
answer to yourself which of these is the
most right similarly we can ask with the
expedient not everything that's
expedient is is inherently compatible
with everything else that's expedient or
useful which of the useful things are in
fact more useful people get mixed up
about this all the time that's why you
can make money off of people selling
them garbage because they exchange money
which is indeed a useful good for other
things that turn out to be quite
valueless but which they mistakenly
assume to have greater value so this is
a part of thinking about our duties and
what we ought to do right we ought we
shouldn't transgress the right we know
that we shouldn't favor the expedient
over the right but if two things are
expedient and we can have one but we
can't have the other that also fits into
the realm of duty for Cicero and it's
worth thinking about so this provides a
sort of comprehensive scope for what
this work on duties is going to grapple
with
you